hey guys it is the 25th of every today
my name is Jess McDonald and you are
watching games but news first up Xbox
one has to extreme in finally or at
least it will format 11 microsoft
announced the news through the xbox wire
and if that March date sounded familiar
it's because this feature will come into
play just in time for titanfall as a
reminder this surface is only available
to xbox live gold subscribers but if
that's you then there's no limit to the
amount of engaging or not so engaging
content you can stream straight to the
web speaking of titanfall that game is
going to be huge but not in the way that
you're thinking Microsoft and EA are the
wife's known as the people who give you
bad news about titanfall as opposed to
respawn have confirmed that the xbox one
version of the game will require up to
14 gigabytes of space to install on xbox
one this news came out of the fine print
of the titanfall Xbox one bundle
announcement on Twitter Vince Zampella
said that the pc version will be 21
gigabytes to download and forty eight
gigabytes to install you guys seem
pretty divided between saying this is
the new normal and freaking out over it
but on the whole you mostly just want to
stop hearing about titanfall so let's
move on in news it's making people mad
for whatever reason the Xbox one has
earned itself product of the year for
2014 I'd put my hand up to say that
perhaps February's a little early to
start naming products of the year but
the home entertainment category of
product of the year's annual awards back
in whorls good the xbox one one as a
result of a survey conducted on 40,000
consumers by a market research firm but
we don't know much about the survey
construction or other runner-up products
do you guys think this is a fair win or
who do you reckon sure won the 2014
product to be yeah now for something
completely different Marcus off said
something about the xbox one seriously
the remarks of the currently defending
the X
one's price cuts saying it doesn't mean
they're struggling side price cut that
we reported on earlier is merely about
giving UK game is the best value they
can that's according to champion of
Microsoft and possible superhero harpy
eagle the microsoft exec defended the UK
price card which was one of the fastest
in modern console history basing that it
is absolutely to generate more sales and
from our perspective presumably to get a
little closer to that ps4 price how much
do you want to be paying for an xbox one
let me know in the comments down below
or you can do so on my Twitter where I'm
at Justin stuff and those are all the
stories from the xbox one realm that
I've got for you today but be sure to
let me know if you know of any other
good stories about anything else and I
will see you again tomorrow